[Music]  in a hot pan sweat shredded leeks along  with a knob of butter and season next  great Powerball potatoes and Greer a  hard Swiss cheese with a great nutty  flavor  then combined with a soft release in a  pan heat oil and a little butter spoon  in the potato leek and cheese mix cook  gently until golden and crisp underneath  then slide onto a plate flip over and  return to the pan to finish cooking  [Music]  finally for the perfect topping fry two  eggs and place them on top of the Rasta  top with fresh tarragon  [Music]  leaking kriya rusty with fried eggs are  simple but substantial dish that makes  the most of hearty root veg  [Music]